what's going on guys Bang Bang the big
story this week is that silvergate bank
has decided to wind down operations and
liquidate their Assets Now silvergate
bank is an essential piece of
infrastructure for the crypto ecosystem
and they have been a great supporter of
crypto businesses over the last couple
of years now falsely many people will
publicly claim that silvergate bank got
in trouble because they supported the
crypto industry but that is not true
instead silvergate bank had a number of
long duration bonds and assets on their
balance sheet and as those assets got
underwater silvergate bank got into a
position where they needed more cash
than they had available and therefore it
made sense to wind down the business to
prove that silvergate bank did not end
up shutting down because of their crypto
customers we then can move on to Silicon
Valley Bank which is in the same exact
situation Silicon Valley Bank went from
about 62 billion dollars in deposits
back in 2019 to about 190 billion
dollars in deposits at the end of 2021
now during that time they took about 80
billion dollars of those fresh deposits
and they bought long duration assets
including about 97 percent of that money
going into 10-year mortgage-backed
Securities the reason they did this is
because we were in a low interest rate
environment and they needed to get
higher yield those 10-year maturity
assets allowed for them to earn over 1.5
percent which sounded great when
interest rates were at zero but now that
interest rates have been increased to
about 4.5 percent those long duration
assets are trading underwater and the
banks holding them are in big big
trouble now Banks don't necessarily have
to realize those losses they could
simply hold those assets until maturity
and be perfectly fine but the problem is
when a bunch of different depositors
show up and they want to withdraw their
assets the banks need to get the money
from somewhere and so they're forced to
sell those assets at a loss recently
Silicon Valley Bank reported that they
sold 21 billion dollars of their medium
duration assets and they took a 1.8
billion dollar loss on the sale this
then led to another announcement this
week which included a 2.25 billion
dollar equity and debt offering to try
to shore up the balance sheet and a 500
million dollar investment from General
Atlantic now customers and Market
participants got spooked when they heard
this announcement they had just seen
silvergate Bank wind down operations and
intend to liquidate assets they saw a
1.8 billion dollar loss on the sale of
the 21 billion dollars of Securities and
they saw a capital raise which made them
think maybe Silicon Valley Bank isn't
doing so hot and so in Mass people ran
and started to withdraw assets and the
full-on bank run ensued this then led to
the halting of the stock and a 70
drawdown in the stock price in less than
24 hours and now Silicon Valley Bank has
hired advisors and they're going to sell
their business this type of contagion
and this type of pressure to financial
organizations is because there is Market
intervention from central banks when you
have a market environment that has a
zero percent interest rate environment
and there's that artificial suppression
of the interest rate and then you whip
it back up over four percent in a matter
of 18 months that causes an
inappropriate ability for these Banks
and these Financial organizations to
plan what is going to happen they don't
know what to do and so if they got
caught holding long duration assets and
there's lots of people who want their
money you have a duration mismatch both
in the case of silvergate bank and
Silicon Valley Bank duration mismatch is
a story as old as time in the finance
industry but Bitcoin also suffering at
the hands of some of the pressure in the
Legacy Financial Market that is down
about 12 13 over the last week some of
that is because silvergate bank is
supporting crypto companies and now
they're worried they may not be able to
get Fiat currencies into the system and
some of that is just because there's
overall pressure in finance and Bitcoin
tends to be more of a free market asset
the last story of the past week that's
worth calling out is that Joe Biden has
all big big new proposal when it comes
to taxes the specific element to the
Bitcoin industry is that he wants to add
a 30 tax to bitcoin miners who consume
energy I think this is ridiculous and we
should not be selecting out certain
industries and their consumption of
energy but even though Joe Biden has
proposed this plan there's a nearly zero
percent likelihood that it gets passed
because the house is controlled by the
Republicans so keep your head on a
swivel out there there's immense
Financial pressure both in the
nutritional market and in the crypto
market and of course politicians will
keep proposing all sorts of ridiculous
plans but we continue to watch Bitcoin
produce block after block after block of
transactions and Bitcoin self-custody
may be one of the safest places in the
entire world right now I hope you enjoy
these updates and I'll talk to all of
you next Saturday